how's it looking for the prime minister
today are you worried about this vote no
i'm not worried at all in fact i'd like
to get this vote out of the way so that
we can get on focusing on the issues
that really need to be focused on you
know today russia is firing rockets into
kiev we've got a global cost of living
crisis because we can't get wheat out of
kiev to the rest of the world there are
some really huge issues which the prime
minister needs to focus on and we as a
cabinet and government do too so this is
a distraction we want to get this out
the way and then move on with the
business of government tomorrow and the
dean doris what does the prime minister
need to get garnet in terms of support
for you to feel that this matter has
been put to bed and he's safe oh beth
i'm not going to talk about numbers if
he got you know a majority of one that's
enough to move on you know
i think the most substantial point is or
the substantive point is that 14 million
people voted for the prime minister in a
general election the biggest vote that a
prime minister conservative prime
minister has had since margaret thatcher
i find it utterly bizarre that a small
number of mps think that they can
overrule that vote
that that vote of 14 million people it's
quite something that they think they can
do that and so you know let's get this
vote done let's let's move on tomorrow
um the prime minister is going to to win
comfortably tonight and we can move on
detractors of the prime minister say
it's not a small number of mps it's
actually dozen
of his own mps and that this hasn't been
organized and it really is on their
conscience that they feel they can't
support him anymore at least 54 letters
i mean that is not that's not just a
small handful is it
so there are
350 plus mps it relatively it is but
anyone who says that this isn't being
coordinated and isn't being
organized behind the scenes i'm afraid
is not telling you the truth this is a
very well organized campaign it's a
perfect storm for some it's remainers
who are taking in others who are
disaffected and for a number of reasons
those who who lost their jobs in cabinet
or as ministers and i'm afraid anyone
who says that this isn't organized is
not telling you the truth it is a very
well organized campaign by a small
number of individuals some who believe
that they should be the next prime
minister which individuals well you know
i'm not going to say but it's a small
number of individuals who've organized
and whipped up this store and i'm afraid
we're going to reach a point where
people aren't going to vote for the
conservative party because people don't
vote for divided parties so we need to
get this vote over and done with and
those mps need to hear a clear message
you know we know just now that the
conservative party donors have said
themselves that they aren't going to
support the party if if the prime
minister is removed i think a number of
mps in marginal seats need to hear that
and and need to understand what they're
doing 18 million pounds those donors
have donated to the conservative party
over recent times it's those those
donors that have helped us to win the
election and they need to hear that
message and nadine dory's just in terms
of divided parties not winning elections
there's been a bit of uh
a bit of agitation around should i stay
today about uh you'll know about this
about some tweets between you and jeremy
hunt jeremy hunt saying it's time for
change and you you said you said if
you've been leader you'd have handed the
keys of number 10 to corbyn you've been
wrong on almost everything you're wrong
again now that's what you said to jeremy
hunt um
that that's kind of exacerbating this
civil war isn't it what's your response
to that because jeremy hunt today has
come out himself i'm surprised you
haven't mentioned this has come out
today himself and said that he is time
for change i think what he means is it's
time for him and you know i don't want
to talk about individual personalities
but what i would say is that you can't
say
repeatedly that you're not going to
challenge the prime minister while as a
war in ukraine and on the day russia
fires rockets into kiev decide that it
is time for a change of leader i'm
afraid that's just not acceptable and i
don't want to talk about personalities
but i'm afraid sometimes it just has to
be said
there are individuals who do believe
that they who don't like brexit who are
remainers who have been able to whip up
a number of mps in the party and i'm
afraid that's just not acceptable the
donors have spoken today some key people
in the conservative party that you will
you will hear about and see over the
next hours um a large number of mps
believe that they should be listening to
their constituencies and the prime
minister should remain imposed and you
know there's one other important point
back if you just forgive me the prime
minister delivered brexit against the
odds he personally drove the vaccine
program he personally drove the testing
program he personally drove the decision
to lift all restrictions coverage
restrictions in the uk we have the
lowest unemployment rate since 1974. we
are in we will be in economic growth the
price the bank of england have decided
we have one of the lowest inflation
rates he's got every big call right
nadine is just as an aside actually also
you said to jeremy hunt your pandemic
preparation during six years as health
sexuals found wanting and inadequate
your duplicity right now is
destabilizing the party and country to
serve your own personal ambition i mean
you were a health minister
is that an admission that the pandemic
preparation was not good enough under
the conservative government
so we we're and we're not going to
rewrite what happened though we know the
the world health organization report and
other reports which have come out since
the pandemic we know we did particularly
well but we did particularly well
because of the way the prime minister
boris johnson handled the pandemic and
matt hancock i might say handled the
pandemic and drove the uk through the
pandemic to a point where because of our
vaccination program because of our
testing program we were one of the few
countries in the world if not the only
country that could lift all covered
restrictions and open for business again
boris johnson got it right on the
pandemic he made the right calls jesse
norman who is married you'll know to the
vaccine task force minister kate bingham
who was
the person that helped deliver with with
the support of the prime minister and
former health secretary matt hancock
that vaccine rollout he has been
absolutely excoriating about the prime
minister today well as i said there are
a number of people anybody who says that
this isn't coordinated in a drip drip
way by certain individuals behind the
scene is at the scene is not telling you
the truth just just finally nadine does
you're you're a cabinet minister you're
one of the most senior sorry sorry sorry
you're one of them say my name
i quite like saying your name let's just
keep going um you you um
you're one of the most senior cabinet
ministers you're one of the boris
johnson's biggest supporters but this
sort of attack on attack on uh jeremy
hunt is it's quite personal i mean some
people some people would say that it's
sort of the meaning of the office of a
cabinet minister to make such personal
blue and blue attacks against a
colleague who doesn't agree with the
prime minister i mean he's allowed to
disagree i mean what do you say to those
people that are quite shocked by what
you've said of jeremy hunt today
well
if they're shocked it's because they're
probably people who are going to vote
against the prime minister anyway and
what i would say is probably demeaning
of a former cabinet minister and
somebody who puts themselves forward as
a potential leadership candidate to
repeatedly say they're not going to
issue a challenge while we're at war
with ukraine and then on the day russia
fires rockets into kiev issued that
challenge one of the rebels said to me
that um that your uh your intervention
today is one of the jeremy hunt's best
weapons are you helping him
by being so aggressive towards him i
mean what do you say to that i say it's
nonsense and that what they're unhappy
with is the fact that you know that
tweet threat that you're talking about
begins with the fact that jeremy hunt
rang me on the 23rd of july 2020 to tell
me that the way to handle a pandemic was
to remove people who tested positive
from their homes and to put them into
isolation hotels that's how jeremy hunt
would have handled the pandemic but you
know it's that that's and kind of that
um revelation i think has angered a few
people but i'm afraid it's factual and
and i'm only repeating what was factual
and just finally nadine the prime
minister you you say he's gonna win the
vote tonight i mean precedent would
suggest that sitting prime ministers
tend to win confidence votes um
but is he a dead man walking i he can
survive but he can't
recover once he's lost the support of
dozens of his mps and also the
confidence of many people
out there in the public so i'd say the
only vote that matters are the 14
million people who voted for in the
general election
the prime minister won the biggest
majority of any conservative prime
minister margaret thatcher it's kind of
a slight day of madness today but i hope
we get through this vote tonight we will
get through this vote tonight and we can
move on tomorrow no he isn't a dead man
walking because as i said he's got every
single big decision right and really
that's all people should be focused on
cost of living crisis war in ukraine the
big decisions that need to be made
moving forward we need our prime
minister to be focused
many of your mps would also say you've
been consistently trailing in the polls
the prime minister's personal ratings
have collapsed
they will be looking at their seats if
they're marginal being very worried that
they are going to lose their seats that
the prime minister has become a drag
anchor
on the conservative brand like once he
was you know he was the superstar and
now he's the drag anchor and you you
might disagree but you can understand
why some of your colleagues are worrying
so i'll answer that but i'll just make
one more point we also have the lowest
unemployment rate since 1974 delivered
by this prime minister but yeah and the
highest inflation in in four decades i
mean i know that's a global issue as
well but but my point is is that there's
lots of
anxiety in the us and many countries
low unemployment but other very worrying
things going on in the economy but but
beth you're quoting a situation which is
beyond the control of the prime minister
which is the war in ukraine which has
caused global inflation rates to rise we
are lower in the uk in terms of
affliction rates than a number of
countries in the u in the eu who are
seven and a half percent i think we're
at seven percent and the us which i
think is eight to nine percent so it's a
global inflation crisis a global
economic crisis and we are doing well in
the circumstances and that's thanks the
prime minister andrew okay so finally
i've got that's making me go back but
i'd like to carry on but finally nadine
what's your message to those rebels
tonight
vote for the prime minister because
that's what 14 million people in the
country did a general election you know
everybody always writes off boris
johnson they wrote him off before two
mayoral elections they wrote him off
over brexit when he delivered brexit and
they wrote him off before the 2019
election he's a winner who always
delivers if they want to win their seat
to the next general election they need
to vote for bryce johnson tonight